[Music]
okay
everyone in this room raise your hand
who is not
twitter verified
youtube wait wait i was instagram
verified
i think i was and it went away all three
businesses
include youtube i wasn't it went away i
don't know why it went away
oh weird yeah i used to be i used to be
twitter well you're then you're in this
group right here raise your hand
oh actually it was youtube verified oh
[ __ ] no i'm talking about twitter i know
but i made a mistake i i'm not twitter
verified
okay raise your hand high five okay so
uh all right so on july 15th
on twitter anyone that was verified not
anyone but most people that yeah you
couldn't tweet
couldn't tweets because yes crypto
article
7 yes oh yes several high
profile twitter accounts got hacked whoa
there are some examples like jeff bezos
it says i have decided to give back to
my community
all bitcoin sent to my address below
will be sent back
doubled i am only doing a maximum of 50
million i believe it and then there's a
link enjoy
50 million bill gates
elon musk whoa kanye west joe biden
barack obama and others and so
and all to the same address there was
two different addresses
but they were just people were probably
throwing money out of
that because you why wouldn't you
believe that by the way this has been a
common scam for like years now in the
crypto space like vitalik buterin has
had
vitalik not giving away eth
he invented ethereum in his [ __ ]
twitter handle he had to have it there
for years like the new nigerian prince
yes they would always say that hey i
they would make a similar looking
to viktalik um name and like have a
couple digits off in his actual name
and there's like he's like i'm giving
away ethereum right now everything you
send me i'll send you back too
so it was the same thing it's going on
for at least five years now or
that one's like a little bit different
because it's like a side account
right that just has a few numbers so
that's the unfortunate part is that that
a lot of people who aren't into crypto
don't understand it as much
who don't know the scam are targeted
yeah so the hackers
actually got like over a hundred
thousand dollars
oh i can't feel so bad yeah and until
this day like even though it's been
announced like oh [ __ ] it's a
it's a scam don't do it like they're
still sending money in so
wow yeah people didn't get the scam note
why wouldn't they just take the [ __ ]
tweets down so
they did too fast yeah there was just so
many
and so they tried to control this as
best as they could to the point where
a lot of verified twitter account users
weren't able to tweet anything and then
the only way that they
could communicate was by retweeting
others so then there was a lot of good
memes out of that [ __ ]
like you like uh you know the stranger
things wall with like the alphabet
lights they were like verified users
right now trying to communicate that's
funny
jokes on them because i never tweet
yeah so then a lot of uh accounts
they were just like what the [ __ ] like
we're all getting punished for this like
we can't
move on you'll live if it's just one day
because a lot of people use this i can't
tweet right now i'm verified too
verified sorry
the non-verified people like everyone
else on twitter were like
yay finally it's our time twitter's free
oh yeah that's so funny you know what's
ironic about this though
is that the idea of crypto is to
decentralize everything so that there's
not one entity that you can attack to
take down the system
and this was like a centralized attack
right like you attack twitter
you can hack twitter at a centralized
location and
get and get into all these accounts and
that's obviously what they did
so you know how they did it they are
reporting
that they actually compromise one of the
twitter employees so it was done from
weekend
exactly yes how did they compromise them
well like by bribing them or something i
don't know they're investigating
yeah honey pot operation
yeah so they're best investigating right
now exactly what happened
but twitter announced they said they
said this we detected
what we believed to be a coordinated
social engineering attack by people who
successfully targeted some of our
employees with access to internal
systems and tools
so once they figured that out they
completely like
removed access from most twitter
employees
and that's the reason why a whole bunch
of verified accounts weren't able to
tweet either
they were just trying to figure out like
what the [ __ ] happened here
who the [ __ ] did this like who who took
the bribe
that's amazing yeah and then a lot of
people were really concerned because
they were like well what the [ __ ] like
there's a lot of politicians and like
very crucial like disastrous things can
come out of a hack like this
oh yeah yeah like we [ __ ] we're gonna
start wars yeah exactly
we launched we launched a war at russia
or who the [ __ ] knows we launched a an
atomic bomb at somebody like and the way
our president [ __ ] tweets all the
time
people would buy it how how crazy is it
that they didn't even get into
his account and he still tweeted crazy
[ __ ]
that's wild yeah my conspiracy behind it
is that you know how they're trying to
control social media right now
what if they're doing this like they
have an agent to get through the cracks
to show
see they do need regulation they need
government
oh no uh oh well they did mention
that donald trump our president
that he will know like he he won't stop
using twitter and that
oh is completely secure and that there's
no reason for
american citizens how's that possible
deny or ever be
don't worry it's always him it's like
okay okay good
damn it we're trying to give you an
ounce of like leeway here like maybe you
got hat
or maybe at least let his pr person have
access he's like no no no it's me it was
me
when i'm talking [ __ ] that's me he's
like when i took a [ __ ] on tom ridge
this morning that was me
do you guys follow him tom ridge no no i
follow
wait is it the real donald trump or
there's another meme account it's that
real donald trump
i follow that guy on instagram the real
donald trump yeah is he
that's the fake one no it's the real one
barack obama follows me
that's sick does he yeah wow you steal
this
i could dm him i think i saw him
unfollowed
dang yeah i don't know i just i'm so
exhausted from
everything that i'm like i can't follow
these people twitter is
more of a crazier place though instagram
it's like you can balance
yeah it's like you'll follow people
you can follow like nature people or
whatever you can control
what it is but twitter this is
everything is this everything
everything is like roasting talking [ __ ]
raising
the funniest [ __ ] out there but they
also just are crazy on there and it's
also because you can see
what other people that you follow
they're they're they like
so then that [ __ ] starts popping up in
true or even what they follow
yeah just in a whole account and then
like one tweet pops up just because
someone that you follow follows this
account
yeah and that stuff gets like oh it's
non-stop
yeah it's pretty crazy too cause um back
in like 2013
one of the things like was to boost your
to boost your followers you could do
these like
one-hour tweeting follow-backs so like
anyone that follows you you follow them
back for that hour
so i followed like a thousand or two
thousand people like random people i
have no idea who they are
they followed me in 2013 during that
hour
and it's the widest variety of people i
have
ever seen so why don't you unfollow
follow him i choose this because it's
interesting
there's probably only like 50 people i
actually know that i follow
and then everyone else is just like
random people and i get to see like what
the world is like because
it's like outside of the bubble so i get
to see like what
people talk about that i don't know and
it runs the gamut
that's how i feel when i'm playing grand
theft auto online
because i'm like dude i'm like in
people's houses from all over america
all over the world
i'm hearing the same arguments in
different languages
english spanish every language
everyone hates each other like they're
not paying attention to their poor kid
who's just sitting there playing the
game
and like like there's random [ __ ]
noises in the background like fans and
like
dark barking dogs that's actually what i
discovered from the window swap
website i'm like every person has
creaky ass floors floors all of it you
can hear
and then there's someone's like clacking
on somebody being like close the [ __ ]
window we got the air conditioner on
and [ __ ] like you hear all that [ __ ] and
so i'm like man everyone's the same it's
so beautiful that's why when you play
gta you're just like
this is not that different from real
life it's not it's crazy
especially online with the microphone
man that's just hilarious
yeah well back to twitter here so they
were saying that people who hacked
they ended up having access to direct
messages as well oh
[ __ ] to certain accounts they saw my
ones to barack obama
and he replied yeah they were saying
that they were able to
get into some dms which is like wearing
a lot of people
worrying a lot of people they were in
bezel's dm
yeah oh i would like to know
what what poncho goes in and he's like
he's responding to kids that are like do
you like hamburgers he goes i prefer hot
dogs
you know like it's like something i wish
it was innocent like that you can't say
hot dog i was the best
that i was like hot dogs and pizza oh
okay okay okay
sushi sushi how about sushi yeah yeah
okay you're good okay sushi what's your
favorite color you know [ __ ] like that
hanging chief
oh [ __ ] that's pretty good that was
really good
scary times no i hate it right now
i know i hate this within the next 10
years though i promise you you will see
the rise of a social media platform that
is blockchain based where it is
decentralized there is no point of
attack like this
all right nerd that's kind of [ __ ] okay
really in 10 years
within 10 years create an account you
don't need anyone to prove it or
anything like that it's just not owned
by anyone no kyc
know your customer there's no like sign
up an account blah blah blah like you
use a
meta mask or one of those um things to
connect with you can
upgrade it and change the skin yeah
and it'll probably be yeah exactly it'll
be almost white label where you can just
kind of
yeah so what if there's like something
crazy that happens on there like
doxing or some [ __ ] like how do you find
out who the people are
uh how do you mean well like how do you
find out who those people are because
it's all anonymous but right now
if you're logging on twitter like they
have all your info but
you won't you won't know how to you
won't be there so that's scary
yeah well it's scarier i don't think
it's scary don't they oh i think well it
depends it depends on how you look at it
right because because the
the crypto community right now like like
everything that we're talking about
right now so
hundred thousand dollars just got taken
and you know what the crypto community
has done
they have like flagged this address and
everyone's watching this address right
now and so no matter where they move the
[ __ ] money
and this has happened many times before
there's been many hacks and there's all
kinds of
uh wallets that have gotten flagged so
they can't move this money to an
exchange the exchanges immediately they
can see where it's going to grab it
right and that's so there are points of
attack
within this decentralized system where
you could still
have some kind of authority i see yeah
and it's the people's authority
exactly it's the people all deciding
together yeah we're just being a
collaborative thing that's happening
right now and it's organic there's no
like
one person pushing it there's no
president of the company who's saying
everyone let's watch this wallet
everyone as a community is going this is
[ __ ] up let's all watch this together
which is cool
that is really wow kinda like anonymous
the color just all really like about the
good cause
that's from what i understand i don't
know because anyone can
like you could be a government agent and
upload an anonymous video
it's it's a lot of people think that
they got co-opted by the cia
well a lot of the top hackers of
anonymous did get
caught yeah exactly and then they get
caught and they get turned and they work
for
yeah so so it's not really decentralized
like
a true decentralized thing would be like
if
it's more of an idea so so like if they
take out a few members
they can't stop it because
anybody could fill in the place if they
believe in the idea of anonymous
[Music]
do
you